I'm actually here to make a challenge to people.
I know there've been many challenges made to people.
The one I'm gonna make is that it is time for us to reclaim...
...what peace really means.
Peace is not "Kumbaya, my Lord."
Peace is not the dove and the rainbow, as lovely as they are.
When I see the symbols of the rainbow and the dove, I think of personal serenity.
I think of meditation.
I do not think about what I consider to be peace,...
...which is sustainable peace with justice and equality.
It is a sustainable peace in which the majority of people on this planet...
...have access to enough resources to live dignified lives,...
...where these people have enough access to education and health care,...
...so that they can live in freedom from want, and freedom from fear.
This is called "human security".
The Women's League of Burma,...
...11 individual organizations of Burmese women came together because there's strength in numbers.
Working together is what changes our world.
The Million Signatures Campaign of women inside Burma working together...
...to change human rights, to bring democracy to that country.
When one is arrested and taken to prison, another one comes out and joins the movement.
Recognizing that if they work together, they will ultimately bring change in their own country.
In my view, what we need today is people getting up and taking action...
...to reclaim the meaning of peace.
It's not a dirty word. It's hard work every single day.
And if each of us who cares about the different things we care about...
...got up off our butts and volunteered as much time as we could,...
...we would change this world.
We would save this world and we can't wait for the other guy,...
...we have to do it ourselves. Thank you!